Apple put out the new goggles you guys
saw it yeah the uh via I watched um
Marquez
I watched Tech Windows uh oh yeah I know
I watched brownlee's uh uh review of
them which was fantastic you guys should
go check it out
um
and he's gonna break it down way better
than us and anything that we say here is
all going to be stolen from him but uh
it is uh it's really interesting it's
really interesting what's your take
um
one thing I thought was really cool the
goggles it looks as if they're
translucent Lucent meaning you see the
eyes so if I'm wearing them there's a
mode where you can see my eyes it's
actually not my eyes it is a projection
of the inside of the goggles on the
outside and you can turn that on or off
now when it's quote unquote off right so
or on so you can see my eyes
it lets you know that I can see you and
look at you because I'm looking at
everything around me right so it's
really Jarvis like remember with Iron
Man like you can have multiple screens
going on you can look at your computer
right there and then it will mirror
what's on your computer because it's
obviously synced up to all the Apple
stuff and then just pop it up into
wherever you want in this world and then
you move it around with your fingers all
you have to do to to uh I guess click on
something is just do this with your
fingers
like what Marquez was doing it it was
actually moving it around uh he they
don't show him using it uh he's just
describing his use of it and I'm sure
there's certain limitations yeah but
like uh it's not coming out for another
year I've had like some of the goggles
that are out now have the augmented
reality where you can do that same thing
but you're doing with the controller I
believe either a controller or you
wearing some gloves or the gloves yeah
yeah he's like one of the things he said
is Apple's charging 3 500 for it which
is much more expensive than all the
other goggles on the market and he goes
but like apple often does there is
nothing to compare this to they're
setting a price point because you cannot
literally compare this technology to
anything else out there the fact that
it's registering your eyes so if you're
looking at a certain app
it will
it knows how
like if you're focused in on let's say
your music app it will go to the music
app that's on the screen in front of you
it's like you're looking at a computer
essentially and it will highlight it in
a way and then if you want to click it
you just go like this and it just knows
where your fingers are knows your hands
are it's registering the reality around
you and this fake reality that's
creating in front of you and allowing
you to interface with the fake reality I
mean it's just unbelievable is this not
a little scary to everybody
I think how much we're addicted to our
phones how much that takes us out of
reality I can't sleep for [__] a big
reason is the phone I know how addicted
I am to it you're just immersing
yourself even more with this like
there's no reason to not live with this
all the time
I can just go wherever I need to go do
whatever I got two hour battery life
yeah it's only gonna get better no
you're 100 it's only going to get longer
it's only going to progress quicker I do
think that it creates
um I I understand why you're scared
because it enables you to live your life
completely within a screen yeah and
sorry one more Point nobody there's been
no study that says human beings are
happier with smartphones yeah but they
don't care about our happiness they
don't care about our happiness but
that's another reason I'm a little
fearful it's like this is only gonna and
we don't care whatever we don't care
about your happiness either but but I I
so this what this allows you to do it's
quite interesting it's like okay we've
got you know nine hours of phone time or
seven hours of phone time that you're
doing a day and then I have the Apple
watch so it's like I'm always kind of
part of you this does enable it so that
you can live within a screen your entire
day yeah so you can put that in
eventually you could put these things on
and I'm sure they'll be like really
small versions of them and you can put
them on and you could go about your day
you can order coffee you can FaceTime
this is awesome
you can FaceTime and what the person
sees on FaceTime is a AI generated
version of your face that you first do
with your iPhone
so when you first are setting up the
goggles you it creates this version of
your face and that's what's projected so
you and I are FaceTiming I got the
goggles on you don't see my goggles you
see my face talking to you but it's AI
generated so it looks like you're out
here just talking to me uh no no you
want your regular phone okay you're not
on your goggles you just see me talking
to you but it's not me because I have
the [__] goggles on
now it it probably will feel a little
bit weird it's like okay I'm talking a
computer but eventually exactly like you
yep does it mimic your like if you're
laughing does the AI version laugh or I
imagine okay we'll get there eventually
yeah it's not there now yeah those are
the girls grenades that she was like
technology the trend is that it gets
smaller and closer to your body yeah and
that like as these progress they will go
oh yeah you had a future future yeah
yeah but she was talking about this and
she like called us out like four months
ago really on your pocket yeah she was
like this is gonna happen and it's going
to progressively get better and it's
going to replace the smartphone
so we're not going to be using our
iPhones on a day-to-day basis and this
will be eventually what people are using
whether it's the goggles or whether it's
just glasses or contacts or a neural
Google tried it with the Google Glass
and yeah well Google can never do
Hardware because they just don't have
culture and they just and and it
probably was a little bit before its
time it didn't have like the technology
I don't think people will walk around
with a headset that that that's that big
yeah what I can see them potentially
doing and it apparently it's a little
bit heavy and kind of cumbersome right
now but what I can see somebody doing is
working with it so instead of taking
your laptop to work you take that to
work you know who's not looking over
your shoulder to see if you're actually
doing stuff your boss when you have it
all in your goggles yeah it's going to
get more comfortable you can monitor
things you can text you can do
everything you need in complete privacy
right here and you can see what's going
on in your world around you so it's not
like you can't see what's happening in
the office you're not worried about
somebody like bumping into you or
throwing something at you I can see you
Alex while I'm typing on my computer
right here yeah
sorry real quick multiple people to that
point multiple people work with two
screen two monitors yeah and you can
have four that's the thing I didn't
think people would use this at the
office this will be the new way to work
from home because now you can get rid of
that big desk and get rid of the office
space that you need the four different
computers yeah okay imagine you're a uh
one of these Wall Street guys that has
three different TVs going on the same
time and the Ticker on every single one
of them and all your reports and you're
tapping in between all of them now you
can comfortably be on your couch just
have all your screens right here yeah
she predicted that this will change like
the way people decorate their homes like
interior Decor completely changes
because you know no longer will need
physical workspaces you'll no longer
need physical TVs and then on top of
that you're gonna be able to walk around
and you won't have physical
advertisements so you'll have curated
ads the way you have on your phone that
will pop up in the world virtually as
you're walking through oh wow and then
you can take them off and then there's
no more Billboards that are clogging up
all over the streets question isn't this
kind of the idea of what nfts was like
we're eventually going to live in this
world and the art will be in this world
on these glasses
you might still have billboards cheaper
but those billboards can be curated to
your specific desires and interests
right so there's just a QR code on it or
not a QR code but whatever the
equivalent is it's a green screen it is
whatever it is in a city would actually
probably look uglier like this or maybe
they find a way where it can look
beautiful right it's like um the
billboard itself can just be a piece of
art when you don't have the goggles on
it also doesn't matter because we're all
here anyway they do that they do that
for soccer games where they'll the
little Banner that goes around the field
changes depending on where you live is
they'll change that smart smart but
they'll still be Billboards because not
everyone will be able to afford this
most people actually won't be so they'll
probably just be more Billboards
it's only going to get cheaper it's only
going to get more accessible eventually
people are gonna have it but what I
thought was really interesting about
this is the um
the cool thing in the future when they
have the neural link and then you have
these things so then you don't even have
to do the whole clicking with your hand
it's like you're just thinking
everything you want to do Spotify and
play the song and you're just thinking
in your head yeah that's gonna be the
next shift
yeah but everyone predicted it was going
to be VR whereas like that nft space
where things were like all virtual
you're putting on the Oculus and now
you're just like completely immersed in
this quote-unquote Universal reality
yeah and it seems like AR as of right
now is like the better bet where it's so
much better and don't get me wrong VR
creates way funnier videos for the
internet like people fighting a wall and
running into [__] freaking out climbing
on like a little rail over New York but
AR creates the Comfort to actually work
yeah I would feel uncomfortable
if I was doing work in an office and I
didn't know who was next to me close to
me around me anything yeah that's weird
like you'd think that you'd bang your
coffee there's so many things that could
that was my issue with the Oculus just
like trying to watch a movie on her like
play a game with it is like I would
constantly be like is there someone
right here no that's the thing it has
that so this is already built it like it
has done what I'm saying is with this
what we're saying is you can opt into it
but it exists also in augmented reality
where you can see is augmented you can
see everything around you yeah yeah so
which I think is important for most of
the use like if you're checking email
you're looking at all these other things
you want to be able to see the
environment around you if you're
watching a movie and you want to totally
lock in sit down you know you're not
moving lock in and if at any point in
time you want to see what's going on
around you you just turn it on so
there's a space for both but this allows
you to live your day-to-day yeah and
then when you really want to go into the
VR world you do that in that alone this
is more functional for day to day yeah
100 and I think that's what Apple
realized
yeah I think that's what Apple realized
about it also I thought it was really
smart that's what I was going to say the
uh the fact that they're announcing it a
year ahead of time
so it's not coming out for a year and
they did that so that the companies
start making apps for this because it's
a different operating system yeah it's
the vision operating system or The
Vision Pro operating system right you
basically have a computer in your head
that's what it is yeah and so they're
going to make their apps for it so by
the time it comes out you're not limited
like when Oculus came out you could play
one game where you grab the [__] gun
and you shoot the [__] in the
environment like there wasn't just a lot
to do with it and for me I bought them
and then since I really couldn't do that
much with it or I felt I couldn't do
that much with it I just kind of lost
interest this it's got to be seamless
yeah the second I put it on I got my
email I got my Apple ID everything's
ready to go I'm watching movies I'm on a
flight with it yeah think about us when
we're flying almost every weekend
like yeah on a flight this is amazing
yeah I like the fact and uh Brownlee
point this out but I like the fact that
the battery pack is external because it
takes away the weight off your head
adding all the weight to the already
heavy thing [__] up you have it
external and it's just something that
you plug in and then it can be in your
pocket or it can be your backpack or
whatever the hell it is so then it
almost feels like a headphone wire yeah
and then you can get two battery packs
if you're going and you need more than
two hours you know you're not going to
be vlogging directly into the wall yeah
yeah exactly so and I Apple historically
has done a good job of like making cool
technology completely consumable by
everyone where it's like okay the
computer is like this Niche thing that
people are using in specific spaces
let's democratize it where everyone can
use it like the Palm Pilot and like work
phones is like a very Niche thing for
like business people Blackberry let's
democratize it everyone can get a phone
and hopefully this does the same thing
where it's like okay the Oculus is cool
it's within this Gaming Community and
people are using it for specific stuff
let's democratize it everyone can use it
everyday life so it'll be interesting if
they can do it again if they can I feel
like this is be like the third or fourth
time that they've successfully done it
so what would we
what can we think what would we use it
for Miles I know that you're into the
tech stuff like what are you looking
forward to using
The Vision Pro for uh I don't know
that's the hardest one for me is like
it's cool they're giving developers a
year to use it because I remember when
the Apple watch first came out they did
the same thing they gave it like six
months until it actually came out and
then they gave it to a bunch of people
to actually make apps for and in the
beginning I was like I'm not gonna want
an Apple Watch when it first was
announced I was like it doesn't
itch anything for me so I'm excited to
see what use cases developers come out
for with it same thing with Apple watch
in the beginning I was like I don't know
if Apple watch is that impressive and
now I'm like yeah apple watches are
wildly impressive tax call the ultra all
of that's gone really crazy and done
cool stuff so with the headset you'll
see you're gonna use it it's so eager to
try it out but I don't know the exact
use cases yet and I'm excited to see
other people find those use cases you'll
see someone use it and go oh I could do
that yeah that's kind of what happened
with me with the Apple watch is I saw
you guys using your I mean competing
with workouts or something like that and
I was like oh okay it can track certain
things yeah yeah Alex you probably use
Oculus the most out of all of us well I
did that but just like you I lost
interest like this I still don't really
see a time I can use it but I can see uh
streamers loving this because if it can
mimic your face now it's like I can be a
twitch streamer a YouTube streamer and
it's looking like you're looking
straight at me and at the same time
those streamers are looking at multiple
screens while they're pulling up stuff
and all that so it's like if you can
integrate that I can stream you're
seeing my face I'm looking at this
screen I'm pulling this video in and
it'll be a much easier setup than having
a camera light and you have your mouse
that you're doing all this clicking it's
better if you're just running around
yeah interesting so I could see some I'm
really excited for the uh for the
content side of things like content
creation and content capture so it takes
three-dimensional photos and videos
using all the cameras on the outside oh
that's right that's going to be like
imagine we're taking 3D videos our kids
are our parents took photos of us on
like film and then we're taking kids uh
pictures of our kids or future kids on
like iPhones
and then like it's gonna be insane to
think that like you're sending video to
someone and you put it on and you're
like in the room watching it it's like
[__] Avengers end game but Tony Stark
and his dad that memory that he just
lives yes you're just in that [__] and
you have to put on the memory yeah you
can just hit the button and then it does
the thing I'm excited to see content
creation this is some old man [__] to
say but it is very cool to see and I
wonder if like past Generations have
felt the same way but it's very cool to
see technology catch up with the movies
yeah that we watched that were
exhibiting technology that was far
beyond our years yeah so what we saw
Tony Stark doing with Jarvis we will
very soon be able to do with the vision
pro versions of it but we have chat EBT
which is something that we can ask
questions get answers to interface two
like Jarvis I mean once they integrate
you know their version of chat gbt with
this yeah think about what's gonna think
about that
Apple's AI yeah let's call it uh [__]
banana whatever is it hey banana can you
bring up uh my schedule for today
schedule pops up on your Oculus you're
brushing your teeth ugh move that thing
to this thing what over here what's the
best way for me to get sushi before
eight o'clock these things have
suggested could you call the maybe you
can maybe could you go on rezzy there's
Auto schedulers and stuff yeah I mean
it's gonna be Jarvis yeah but what I'm
saying is since it's completely
seamlessly integrated within your Apple
world
everything can be done through Siri or
whatever their AI function is whereas
the other Auto schedules you have to go
to that schedule and then it will apply
it to the different schedules right yeah
like ah dude where eventually we're just
gonna be apples
right like is that is that the future
are we just do we just become the
product ourselves that's why I think the
big loser and this is meta because
meta's big bet was we're all going to be
on the metaverse we're all gonna be meta
Facebook we're all gonna be in that
thing we own it's called the metaverse
let's just call ourselves meta so the
meta world what is called the metaverse
it's indistinguishable everybody's gonna
live everybody's gonna be ours that
Apple just body these [__] with
the hardware and then they got the Apple
App Store is Apple gonna
create their content movies TV shows
specifically for the Vision Pro right is
there a way that they can shoot it
like to shoot it I don't know if this
gives you any advantage but like
shooting it
wider than it really would be so that
when you watch it with the Vision Pro
you can actually kind of turn your talk
about Instagram no I'm talking about
like the Ted lasso and all the shows
like yeah so just utilizing 360 cameras
more but then you'd have the light 360
which would be really difficult yeah but
there's like on the Oculus for example
there are YouTube channels that put
stuff up that's 360 yeah
eventually use AI to fill in the gaps
that aren't present yeah what would the
rest of the stadium look like what would
the rest of them I bet you they could
just fill in a generic plate to be like
okay I'm in the soccer stadium yeah and
I'm only seeing this square but the rest
of it would be this dude you know what
else they could do they could shoot
they could shoot wider
I mean things might start to get a
little fuzzy on the edges or but they
could shoot everything just wider film
everything wider crop in for what the
regular folks that don't have the Vision
Pro would be watching and then if you do
have the Vision Pro you can with it
access the the angles yourself just by
looking on the Imagine our podcast yeah
you either a or allowed to jump into
each camera or there's one in the middle
and they're just like able to zoom in
and go this is a shot I want I want to
focus on Andrew oh that's the uh the NBA
games thing my suspicion those are
people space on the couch for everybody
I don't think people will actually want
to do that personally I don't think
people will want to be too immersive too
frequently I think sorry I think if they
can find a way to do it with you the
person you want to watch it with like if
we all wanted to watch a movie and we
found a way we're all sitting in that
[__] we want to watch an NBA game we
find a way we're all sitting Courtside
talking to each other having the
experience we're all watching Game of
Thrones Battle of the bastards in the
battle because right now this is gonna
be your headset and then you're going to
talk to your wife about it yeah
everybody together it might be we can
just chat and have the whole thing my
suspicion is that most people won't do
that my feeling is that they'll be like
okay there'll be a screen where I'm
watching things and then there's also
going to be Instagram and Tick Tock yeah
there's also going to be my email and
that's how I'm currently watching TV
which is like the screen here but mostly
Instagram and then looking up and then
checking my email and kind of flicking
through stuff and I think that's going
to be more what the layout will be and
it won't be necessarily as immersive and
maybe that will be an option but I think
it'll be more like multi-plane with
different softwares yeah I do I do
subscribe to that because that's kind of
how we watch things right now like right
now somebody has this on
they're looking at their phone for
something and there's their laptop where
they're working
and if they have these all those things
could be operating harmoniously and they
could be tuning in to us going back to
their email whatever without even
clicking out of Windows just simply just
kind of looking to the right yeah
slightly and that would be like the
entertainment experience and then I
think the work experience is like oh I'm
doing dishes around the house or I'm
cleaning or I'm going to pick the kids
up from school or whatever and while I'm
driving I'm able to kind of like see a
profile of a thing or my email thread or
my text thread and it's like I mean
seamlessly integrated once once they
have I don't know if they can do this
legally but once the Apple car comes out
then it's just a different version of
that where your uh what is it called the
uh autopilot anyway what is that yeah
where your windshield okay so if you're
on autopilot you don't have to worry
about the driving now your windshield
becomes an interactive screen right and
it's just your computer screen so you're
looking out if you want it's like that
augmented reality thing but it could
also have your movie that's up here your
text coming in Instagram all the other
stuff ah when do they make kid sizes for
this [__] and then just you just bunch
of kids sitting at the restaurant
goggles like no that's I think that's
what will [__] us up I think right now
that like you don't believe that you can
yeah like nothing can you I mean you
were acknowledging earlier like I'm on
my phone way too much yeah but I feel
like
when we
start to interact with a piece of
technology we're like ah this isn't
going to take over my life this isn't
going to do anything to me I'm an adult
I've you know can make my own autonomous
decisions it's once you see a kid
scrolling an iPad non-stop that you go
oh that's an issue yeah they look
addicted to that yeah
it's the only way the parents can calm
that kid down and it's like you see all
these the iPad holders like the rubber
little alien or something they just hand
them out yeah that's the that's for the
plane I would say this restaurants have
gotten so much quieter yes yeah it is I
mean they should you know how they're
like you need a suit jacket to eat here
they should hand kids out get a rubber
iPad yeah you need your iPad or the kid
cannot enter the restaurant uh also I
think the idea of autonomy is like kind
of an illusion with technology in adults
I think they've hacked our brain so much
that we think we're in control of when
we look at the phone we have no [__]
clue Allison we're on the phone because
we're like oh we're autonomous we're
making this decision how many times have
you opened up the phone and not knowing
what the [__] you're looking for and
you're just like why am I on this all
the time they just hack the the [__] out
of our brain that's why I'm also scared
of it because they are in there they
know how we think better than we know
how we think as dope as this looks I
still don't think it's gonna work I
think it'll be another VR Oculus they'll
be a community for it that it works for
but I think the most for most people
especially if you live with someone at
home it's like once you put that thing
on your face it's like that person's
like checked out yeah and that is it
creates a really weird dynamic when
you're at home great call Great call I
walk around my earpods and I have full
conversation like you can literally see
your face I can wave really quickly get
your attention like now if I'm watching
something with this thing on I either
have to yell loudly at you or tap you
they could get you to check you but I'm
saying if it's AR it's like oh you can
still see it yeah but you're still
looking yeah
they have to go in front of you right
get in your line of vision you know it's
it's just not as a media is like yo hey
Mark I could completely agree with you
that was the biggest issue with me when
I got the Oculus is that I was
completely disconnected from my wife
yeah and it was an issue for me it was
an issue for my wife and I understand
that that makes perfect sense so the way
to fix this is to make them glasses and
the only way for them to be glasses is
for them to start like this yeah and
then again
doesn't this look like the first what
was it called the was it the iMac what
was that like there was an Apple
computer that had like the round one
different colors and it had a little
handle on it yeah so the iMac it kind of
almost looks like the first iMac like
it's a little bit like kind of round and
big and it feels bulky now but once it's
the size of your glasses right there and
it will [__] get there
you can be in the it's like your home
yeah yeah I think it just takes longer
than what people think I think it'll
take longer 10 years because they've
been working on Oculus for 10 years and
it hasn't changed fair enough but I
think it's less yeah well who knows who
knows whatever it is it will get there
but in order for it to get there this
has to work if this flops they're not
going to keep improving in keep putting
in the money for r d like yeah but if it
does all right that buy-in fat steep but
maybe they price it at the point where
they're like this is only for the
enthusiasts early investors exactly like
we don't need this to be an iPod we
don't need this to be a iPhone we don't
need to be that type of Sensational
breakout it's priced at a point where
just the people who are obsessed are
going to buy it and we can break even or
make enough money where we can continue
the investment and it's worth it because
I agree the price point is high yeah
this is not like a traditional consumer
good but if the technology is
groundbreaking then the technology will
persist all all of the Apple products in
the beginning were more expensive than I
think you remember like the OG laptops
OG iPod OG and iPhone iMac was thousands
of dollars yeah the original thousands
thousands the original I've the original
MacBooks were sober of seven thousand
dollars in like today's money wow uh
iPods were more expensive you remember
iPhones were incredibly more expensive
super they didn't have you couldn't send
picture messages on the original iPhone
like there's something I remember the
first time phone not being very
impressive it was impressive for the
time but we look back on it it's like
this is damn near primitive so like by
the third or fourth iteration of this
you'll be like oh it's cheaper
ubiquitous and I want it and does more
and does a lot more yeah yeah it's gonna
be really interesting and also there's
going to be other companies getting you
know how Android has started pushing
Apple into doing like a bunch of [__]
that Apple didn't do just that's what
competition does there's going to be
other companies doing their thing now
Oculus will step at the game up whatever
other new companies are trying to come
in they're going to go off of that add
little improvements it's just going to
keep pushing each other yeah thin or
better whatever maybe we'll see